how many people are involved with good
design
so if we looked at swift but look at
historically i mean
this might touch like uh it's almost
like a steve jobs question too
like how much dictatorial decision
making is required versus
um collaborative and we'll talk about
how
that can go wrong or right yeah but yeah
well well swift
so i can't speak to in general all
design everywhere so the way it works
with swift
is that um there's a core team and so
core team is uh six or seven people-ish
something like that that
is people that have been working with
swift since very early days and so
and by early days it's not that long ago
okay yeah
so it became public in 2014 so it's been
six years
public now but um but so that's enough
time that there's a story arc there
okay and there's mistakes have been made
that then get fixed and you learn
something and then you
you know and so uh that what the core
team does is it provides continuity
and so you want to have a okay well
there's a big hole
that we want to fill we know we want to
fill it so don't do other things
that invade that space until we fill the
hole right there there's a boulder
that's missing here we want to
we will do that boulder even though it's
not today keep
keep out of that space and the whole
team remembers of the
remembers the myth of the boulder that's
there yeah yeah there's a general sense
of what the future looks like in broad
strokes and a shared understanding of
that
combined with a shared understanding of
what has happened in the past that
worked out well and didn't work out well
the next level out is you have the uh
what's called the swift evolution
community and you've got in that case
hundreds of people that
really care passionately about the way
swift evolves and that's like an amazing
thing to again
uh the core team doesn't necessarily
need to come up with all the good ideas
you got hundreds of people out there
that care about something and they come
up with really good ideas too
and that provides this like tumbling
rock tumbler for ideas
and so the the evolution process is
you know a lot of people in a discourse
form they're like hashing it out and
trying to like talk about okay well
should we go left or right or if we did
this what would be good and you know
here you're talking about hundreds of
people so you're not going to get
consensus
necessarily you're not obvious consensus
and so
there's a proposal process that then
allows the core team and the community
to work this out and
what the core team does is it aims to
get consensus out of the community and
provide
guard rails but also provide long-term
make sure we're going the right
direction kind of things so does that
group represent like
the how much people will love the
user interface like you think they're
able to capture that
well i mean it's something we talk about
a lot it's something we care about how
well we
how well we do that it's up for debate
but i think that we've done pretty well
so far is the
beginner in mind yeah because you said
the progressive disclosure
yeah so we care a lot about uh a lot
about that
a lot about power a lot about efficiency
a lot about there are many factors to
good design
and you have to figure out a way to kind
of
work your way through that and so if you
like think about
like the language i love is lisp
probably still because i use emacs but i
haven't done anything
any serious working lists but it has a
ridiculous amount of parentheses
yeah um i've also you know with
java and c plus plus uh the braces
um you know i i like i i enjoyed the
comfort
of being between braces yeah yeah well
python is really exciting to interrupt
just like and last thing to me
as a designer if i was a language
designer uh god forbid
is i would be very surprised that python
with no braces would nevertheless
somehow
be comforting also so like i could see
arguments for
all of these so look at this this is
evidence that it's not about braces
versus tabs
right exactly you're good that's a good
point right
so like you know there's there's
evidence that but see like it's one of
the most argued about things oh yeah of
course just like tabs and spaces which
it doesn't i mean
there's one obvious right answer but it
doesn't it doesn't actually matter
what's that
come on we're friends like what are you
trying to do to me here people are gonna
yeah half the people are gonna tune out
yeah
um so so you're able to identify things
that don't
really matter for the experience well no
no
it's it's always a really hard so the
easy decisions are easy
right i mean you you ca fine those are
not the interesting ones the hard ones
are the ones that are most
interesting right the hard ones are the
places where hey we want to do a thing
every agrees we should do it there's one
proposal on the table
but it has all these bad things
associated with it well
okay what are we gonna do about that do
we just take it do we
delay it do we say hey well maybe
there's this other feature that if we do
that first
this will work out better how does this
if if we do this
are we paying ourselves into a corner
right and so this is where again you
having that core team of people that
has some continuity and has perspective
has some of the historical understanding
is really valuable because you get um
it's not just like one brain you get the
power of multiple people coming together
to make good decisions and then you get
the best out of
all these people and you also can
harness the the community around it
what about like the decision of whether
like in python having one type
or having a you know uh strict typing
yeah okay yeah let's talk about this so
so um
i like how you put that by the way like
so so many people would say that python
doesn't have types it doesn't have type
yeah but you're right i've listened to
you enough
to where i'm i'm a fan of yours and i've
listened to
way too many podcasts and videos
oh yeah so i would argue that python has
one type and so
um so like when you import python and
swift which by the way works really well
you have everything comes in as a python
object now here are their trade-offs
because
um uh you know it depends on where
you're optimizing for and python is a
super successful language for a really
good reason
because it has one type uh you get duct
typing for free and things like this
but also you're pushing you're making it
very easy to
pound out code in one hand but you're
also making it very easy to introduce
uh complicated bugs you have to debug
and
you pass the string into something that
expects an integer and it doesn't
immediately die it goes all the way down
the stack trace and you find yourself in
the middle of some code that you really
didn't want to know anything about and
it blows up and you're saying well what
did i do wrong
right and so types are good and bad
and they have trade-offs they're good
for performance and certain other things
depending on where you're coming from
but it's it's all about trade-offs and
so this is
this is what design is right design is
about weighing trade-offs and trying to
understand
the ramifications of the the things
you're weighing like types or not
or one type for many types um
but also within many types how powerful
do you make that type system is another
very complicated question
uh with lots of trade-offs it's very
interesting by the way
but uh but that's like one one dimension
and there's a bunch of other dimensions
jit compiled versus static compiled
garbage collected versus reference
counted versus memory
manual memory management versus you know
like in like all these different
trade-offs and how you balance them or
what make
a programming language good concurrency
yeah so and all those things i guess
uh when you're designing the language
you also have to think of how that's
going to get all compiled down to
if you care about performance yeah well
and go back to list
right so list also i would say
javascript is another example of a very
simple language
right and so one of the so i also love
lisp i don't use it
as much as maybe you do yeah you did no
i think we're both
everyone who loves lisp it's like you
love it's like
i don't know yeah i love frank sinatra
but like how often do i seriously listen
to ranks
sure sure so but but you look at that or
you look at javascript which is another
very different but relatively simple
language and there are certain things
that don't exist in the language
but there's there is inherent complexity
to the problems that we're trying to
model
and so what happens to the complexity in
the case of uh both of them for example
you say well what about
large-scale software development okay
well you need something like packages
neither language has a like language
affordance for packages
and so what you get is patterns you get
things like npn you get things like
you know like these ecosystems that get
built around and
i'm a believer that if you don't model
at least the most
important inherent complexity in the
language then what ends up happening is
that complexity gets pushed
elsewhere and when it gets pushed
elsewhere
sometimes that's great because often
building things as libraries is very
flexible and very powerful and allows
you to evolve and things like that but
often it leads to a lot of
unnecessary divergence in the force and
fragmentation and
and when that happens you just get kind
of a mess
and so the question is how do you how do
you balance that uh
don't put too much stuff in the language
because that's really expensive and
makes things complicated
but how do you model enough of the
inherent complexity of the problem that
um you provide the framework and the
structure for people to think about
you